this video accompanies our paper
presented at HK the international joint
conference and artificial intelligence
where we propose a system for detecting
driver frustration from the fusion of
two data streams first the audio of the
drivers voice and second the video of
the drivers face
let's ask an illustrative question these
are video snapshots of two drivers using
the in-car voice based navigation system
which one of them looks more frustrated
with the interaction to help answer that
question let's take a look at an example
interaction involving the driver on the
right our proposed approach uses the
audio of the drivers voice when the
quote-unquote human is speaking and the
video of the drivers face when he's
listening to the machine speak when
you're seeing and hearing is the driver
attempting to instruct the car's voice
based navigation system to navigate is
177 Massachusetts have Cambridge
Massachusetts 177 that's just sad
Cambridge Massachusetts
and a tub of what 7-7 Massachusetts
Avenue Cambridge Massachusetts
Cambridge Massachusetts so there's your
answer on the scale of one to ten with
one being completely satisfied and ten
being completely frustrated the smiling
driver reported his frustration level
with this interaction to be a nine we
use self-reported level of frustration
as a ground truth for the binary
classification of satisfied versus
frustrated when the driver is speaking
we extract the Geneva minimalistic
acoustic parameter set G Maps features
from their voice which measures basic
physiological changes in voice
production when the driver is listening
we extract 14 facial actions using the
apdex system from the video of the
drivers face the classifier decisions
are fused together to produce an
accuracy of 80 8.5%
on an on-road data set of twenty
subjects there are two takeaways from
this work that may go beyond just
detecting driver frustration first
self-reported emotion state may be very
different than one assigned by a group
of external annotators so we have to be
careful when using such annotations as a
ground truth for other affective
computing experiments second detection
of emotion may require considering not
just facial actions or voice acoustics
but also context of the interaction and
the target of the effective
communication for more information or to
contact the authors please visit the
following website